-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show."
You look good, bud.
How's the fam?
How's --
-Good.
Yeah, we're doing good.
She's -- Wednesday's nearly 3.
-Yeah. Are you proud of
the name Wednesday, seeing --
-Well, yeah, I know.
-Seeing the success of --
I mean, you timed that one out.
-Glad we kind of got in there.
-You were ahead of the curve.
-There's gonna be a boom,
a "Wednesday" boom.
-Oh, everyone's gonna be named
Wednesday next year.
[ Laughter ]
You crushed it!
-It's a good name.
I stand by it.
-What is she interested in?
What is she into?
-Um, so many things.
I mean, she's kind of
princess crazy, as well.
But she's struggling
a little bit with kind of
adjusting to U.K. life.
She spent most of her time
in America, so she's missing
some kind of cultural things --
-Did you film "Servant" here?
Is that --
-We did.
We filmed it in Philadelphia.
So she's --
-Philly, so she loves Philly.
-She does love Philly.
She loves hoagies.
She loves water ice.
-Yeah.
[ Scattered cheers ]
-And, I mean, the big --
the big one -- Yeah.
The big one is Target.
[ Laughter ]
She is obsessed with Target.
-It's unbelievable.
My kids, too.
-Oh, really?
-Loved it!
-She'd choose that over going
to the park, the zoo.
-Over Disney, anything.
"Let's go to Target."
-But she loves going
to different Targets
and kind of seeing how
the layout
is kind of slightly different.
[ Laughter ]
And sometimes
she doesn't buy anything.
She just wants to kind of
browse.
[ Laughter ]
-At the toy aisles?
-The toy aisle is definitely
a draw, but she's more into
lip balm, to be fair.
[ Laughter ]
-She goes to
the lip balm section?
-Lip balm, yeah.
-But she's so into Target
that you built a little
Target play store for her...
-Yeah, I did, yeah.
-...in your house.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Yeah.
[ Applause ]
Just, uh -- yeah.
I think I've -- I think I've
definitely captured the --
[ Chuckles ]
I've captured essence.
-Yeah, well, you have all
the gift cards there,
yeah, absolutely.
-Gift cards, yeah.
-But she's tiny.
How old is she, 2 1/2?
-She's 2 1/2, yeah, yeah.
-So, what does she just roam
around and talk to everybody?
-Yeah, she's chatty.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that she loves Target.
-It was one of the most
difficult conversations
telling her that she lives
in a country
that doesn't have Target.
-Yeah.
Yeah, U.K. does not have --
-We don't have it.
I've shown her the kind of --
our equivalent,
but it just doesn't --
-It doesn't hold up?
No, no.
Well, Target, get on the ball.
Go over -- Let's go --
Let's go global, yeah.
We were talking.
I was like,
"What's one of the first things
you ever bought?"
And I go, "When you got
your driver's license,
what was your car?"
And you had
a very interesting answer.
And I never thought
you were gonna say this,
but the first car that you
bought, you bought a truck.
-I did, yeah.
-Yeah.
You bought an ice-cream truck.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Mr. Whippy.
-[ Laughs ]
It's a great truck.
A great truck.
-Is Mr. Whippy famous in...?
-Yeah, I don't believe --
I guess the equivalent --
It's Mr. Frosty is what --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, it's kind of
an iconic soft serve.
I've always loved the trucks.
-Yeah.
-And it's something
I always wanted to have.
It's nostalgic,
it's the music, it's --
I mean, it's the most
impractical first car.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a terrible first car.
-Because it has one seat,
and the rest of it is --
It's all freezer.
[ Laughter ]
-Where does it -- Where do you
even drive to take your test?
The teacher
can't be in the vehicle.
-Yeah, I know.
I didn't actually --
-Take the test on the thing.
-It was my everyday car
for a while.
[ Laughter ]
-You drove Mr. Whippy around?
-Yeah, I did.
But then it was --
I did feel a little bit
kind of creepy
driving an ice-cream van
with no ice cream in it.
It never had any
ice cream in it.
-You never used it
for ice cream?
-No, the only time I ever did
was actually,
I took it
on the last day of filming
"Deathly Hallows: Part 2."
They had, like, a Mariachi band,
and I brought the van
to sell ice cream to the crew,
and -- yeah.
-So, you did use it.
-I did use it, yeah.
For those kind of events,
it's perfect.
-Is it hard to park this thing?
-It's impossible to park.
And also you have to be careful
where you park.
Because other ice-cream men
are very territorial.
[ Laughter ]
It's dangerous.
-It sounds
like a nightmare to me.
-It's kinda like a Mafia, yeah.
-It sounds like a nightmare.
Before we talk about "Servant,"
I want to talk about --
mention your new film
coming out next month,
called "Knock at the Cabin."
No, no, no, I know.
M. Night Shyamalan,
he's just a genius.
But, I mean,
it looks frightening.
I think the trailer got like
over 22 million views already
'cause people are freaking out,
scared about it.
Are you getting
used to Night at all?
Like, and the twists and turns
that he does?
-Yeah, I am.
I'm kind of getting more
kind of acclimatized to it.
I love Night.
I've kind of got to know him
over the years.
-Did you know
he surprised me once,
just being in the audience
one night, didn't tell me?
-Yeah, I saw -- I saw that.
-It was bizarre.
I was just walking in,
I go,
"Are you M. Night Shyamalan?"
He's like, "How you doing man?"
That's frightening.
You can't just
be in the audience.
-That's classic.
It's classic Night.
It's a twist.
-It's a twist on everything,
yeah.
Let's talk about "Servant."
This is the fourth,
this is the final season.
Congrats on a great run.
But now,
the series coming to an end,
are there questions --
Will they be answered?
Or are they -- is there twisties
and turns in this?
-I mean, yeah,
there's a lot of questions
I think this season kind of
does its best to answer.
And it's great.
It's so nice to be --
become a part of this show.
I love it, I love the cast.
It's been kind of the longest
thing I've been a part of
since "Potter,"
so it's a real family,
and it's --
-Is there anything we can do
to set up this last season,
or set up what's gonna happen,
or no?
-Again, it's really hard for me
to talk about.
I don't want to -- there's so
many kind of loose ends.
But it's a very satisfying
ending, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'll take that.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Rupert Grint
in "Servant."
Take a look at this.
-Fantastic, isn't it?
Her gifts grow every day.
You must be in awe.
-What are you talking about?
-She did this so protect us from
those who wish to do us harm.
Don't you see?
There's a war afoot.
She's shielding us,
shielding your family.
-God, you people
are something else.
Sorry to break it to you,
but I think it's more
of an issue of hygiene
and negligence, not voodoo.
-You can feel it, can't you?
When you're close to her,
there is something
that pulls you in,
tells you that she is the way.
It's her power.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Rupert Grint, everybody!
Season four of "Servant"
premieres this Friday
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Dry Cleaning.
Stick around, everybody.